Que faites-vous lorsque vous avez mal à la tête ?
Vous prenez une aspirine.
Mais pour qu'elle puisse atteindre votre tête, là où vous avez mal,
elle passe d'abord par votre estomac, vos intestins
et autres organes.
Prendre une pilule est le moyen le plus efficace et indolore pour administrer
n'importe quel médicament à l'organisme humain.
Cependant, prendre une pilule va entraîner la dilution de celle-ci.
Et c'est un sérieux problème, surtout pour les malades du VIH.
Quand ils prennent leurs médicaments contre le VIH,
cela réduit le taux du virus dans le sang et accroît celui des cellules CD4.
Mais elles sont également connues pour leurs effets secondaires indésirables
mais le pire, c'est qu'elles se diluent avant même d'arriver dans le sang,
et plus encore, lorsqu'elles arrivent à destination,
là où il faut : aux réservoirs viraux du VIH.
Ces parties du corps-- comme les ganglions lymphatiques
le système nerveux, et les poumons--
là où le virus reste en latence,
et elles ne seront pas administrées facilement dans le sang des malades
qui sont sous traitement anti-VIH constant.
Cependant, en cas d'arrêt du traitement,
le virus peut se réactiver et infecter de nouvelles cellules dans le sang.
Alors, tout ça est un sérieux défaut dans notre traitement actuel du VIH,
traitement à vie qui doit être accepté par les malades.
Un jour, je me suis dit :
« Pouvons-nous administrer les anti-VIH directement aux sites de la maladie,
sans risquer la dilution de la pilule ? »
En tant que scientifique spécialiste du laser, la réponse était sous mon nez :
les lasers, bien sûr.
S'ils peuvent être utilisés en odontologie,
en cicatrisation diabétique et en chirurgie,
on peut les utiliser dans tout ce que vous pouvez imaginer,
y compris, l'administration directe des médicaments aux cellules.
D'ailleurs, nous utilisons actuellement le laser à impulsions
pour créer des passages très minuscules,
qui s'ouvrent et se ferment presque aussitôt dans les cellules malades,
pour administrer les médicaments à l'intérieur.
Vous vous demandez comment c'est possible.
En fait, nous utilisons un faisceau laser très puissant, mais très fin,
à l'intérieur de la membrane des cellules atteintes de VIH
tant que ces cellules sont immergées dans un liquide contenant le médicament.
Le laser transperce la cellule, pour que le médicament pénètre à l'intérieur
en quelques microsecondes.
Et avant de le savoir,
le passage est déjà réparé.
À l'heure qu'il est, nous testons cette technologie dans des éprouvettes
ou dans des boîtes de Pétri,
mais nous voulons appliquer cette technologie sur le corps humain.
Vous vous demandez comment c'est possible.
La réponse est : grâce à un dispositif à trois têtes.
En utilisant la première tête, qui est notre laser,
nous allons pratiquer une incision dans le site de l'infection.
En utilisant la deuxième tête, qui est une caméra,
nous cherchons le site de l'infection.
Enfin, la troisième tête, utilisée pour répandre le médicament,
nous administrons directement le médicament au site de l'infection,
tout en utilisant le laser de nouveau pour ouvrir les cellules.
Eh bien, cela peut sembler un peu difficile à imaginer pour le moment.
Mais un jour, en cas de succès,
cette technologie pourra éliminer le VIH du corps humain.
Oui. Un remède contre le VIH.
Ceci est le rêve de tout chercheur sur le VIH –
dans notre cas, c'est un remède grâce aux lasers.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)